Hey here what delicious healthy snacks
to get you through the afternoon slump I
know it's the three o'clock slop the
worst the worst dietitian Abbi sharpest
with and there's a lot of misconceptions
about snacking people think you need to
cut out snacks if you're trying to
manage your weight right but actually
the research suggests the opposite that
actually planning for healthy snacking
can help you manage your weight by
stabilizing your blood sugar and helping
you make those healthier decisions
rather than those crazy hangry frantic
one right and then you'll be better for
it for Dad so as much Pachulia the right
thing that's right so so planning the
snack so we get snacks so one I'm
looking at how these look like desserts
to me well why not you know I don't have
a little bit of fun we've got some great
snack swaps depending on what you're
craving okay alright so if we're great
what we're gonna go with your section
we're gonna start with this okay what if
for I'm crazy like something like a
little chip filling crunchy something
salty yeah these are crispy chickpeas so
I've got some no-salt-added chickpeas
here a high in fiber high in protein
right obviously a lot lower in fat than
your traditional potato chips so just
give them a light little saute and touch
the touch of olive oil okay I'm adding
lots of flavor here so the idea is you
can add whatever spices you want I've
got some chili and I've got some cumin
but you want to add lots and lots of
space cuz that way you don't need to add
so much salt right yeah it doesn't even
really need that much just like a teeny
weenie pinch okay and I just give it a
light little stir fry and to get them
crispy this is the keys they gotta go in
the broiler uh-huh and they usually take
a couple minutes but that's what's gonna
get them nice and crispy and addictive
like potato chips look how good that it
looks really good yeah so a half a cup
of that you're looking at a hundred
seventy-five calories stay right there
that's gonna see if the front row wants
yeah let them have it
I think about that what do you think I'm
sorry you're tripping here sorry you
guys have some of that I can't give it
to all of you because I don't have
enough for the staff what do you think
what do you think really they're really
good okay good okay here we go next one
amazing okay now if you're craving that
kind of sweet and salty combo
these are my tropical quinoa bite oh so
good so we've got two cups of quinoa
here going into the bowl
yeah lots of fiber protein all that good
stuff we love quinoa mmm I've got some
toasted coconuts which has fiber it also
just feels like tropical and summer a
little vacation we've got some almond
butter now this is the glue but it's
also your fiber your protein this is
what's gonna really keep you feeling
fuller longer get if you don't want all
that you could you pumpkin you do
whatever you want yeah yeah
so I've got some flax seed ground up
flax fiber protein Omega threes really
really really healthy for you I've got
some honey this is only about 2
tablespoons you don't need very much
because all the flavor is really in that
the almond butter which is fantastic and
we've got some freeze-dried fruit and I
love this this is lower in calories
lower in sugar than your traditional
dried fruit than that what's up root
what that was it be your your mango cuz
I want to drop it oh yeah but you can
really use whatever kind of dried fruit
you find have on hand roll these into
balls two balls for 166 calories that's
five grams of protein and five grams so
holla not that they're gonna last cuz
they probably won't yeah but you just
sticks up you're leaving on encounter
you put them in the refrigerator put
them in the refrigerator just because
we've got some you know the almond
butter and everything going in but they
they're fantastic put them in a little
in a little plastic baggie you have them
in your pop them in your purse and you
got them you got them okay that's great
the next thing looks absolutely
delicious if you're craving sweet and
creamy so yeah
so I love ice cream summers coming and
I'm trying to find any excuse to eat ice
cream breakfast lunch and dinner and
snack so this is why I created this
recipe and you're not gonna believe how
easy this is two ingredients caught it's
cheese frozen berries cottage cheese
yeah I know you think it's crazy right
so cottage cheese when you blend it up
it actually gets creamy and dreamy like
ice cream okay so obviously it's high in
protein we've got about 28 grams of
protein in a cup of cottage cheese so
this is low sodium low low so low sodium
low fat okay because when you go and
look at all the cottage cheese there's
like all different variations
yeah absolutely that's someone you want
to get and even if you're still worried
about the sodium my little trick is to
give it a quick little rinsing and that
really kind of gets rid of that sodium
packed moisture that it's like in it
just it I just put in a little colander
oh and you okay and it'll it really gets
rid of that salt there I didn't really
say that much smelt in some of them I
know you don't it doesn't taste salty
but if you actually look at the package
so when we get it should we get like
when we're getting caught as cheese
normally yes just because we were
watching our guys totally what are we
looking for again I'm Sonya I like to
cook I like to pick like a 1% like a
reduced fat or a low fat not a zero fat
well you could choose a zero fat - I
just like the flavor of yeah yeah and
it's negligible fat and alright and then
I use a reduced sodium okay like I said
you can just give it a quick rinse and
go but you can see that whole recipe
right there 189 calories 5 grams of
fiber 19 grams of protein calories and
so you put there you put blueberries and
blackberries and raspberries whatever
berries you have on hand in the in the
freezer but I mean you can have ice
cream before dinner and not feel bad we
were talking about we were talking to
Natasha about you know keeping berries
like and apples and things like that
that's low so when we go grocery
shopping today strawberries are low yeah
blueberries blackberries raspberries
what else all that you mean low and fat
or low just low in sugar low in sugar
absolutely the berries are great because
they're higher in fiber ok she's really
what we want to go for is that
combination of fiber and the protein
that's what's gonna keep us feeling
fuller longer they want to feel fuller
longer okay well thank you Abbi
wonderful job now I know we're gonna
have at 3 o'clock
thanks I'll be seeing more everybody ok
tomorrow on Maryland real estate guru
scott mcgillivray is co-hosting the full
show
you